yes you don't want to use those services
there is an open and unmediated internet
that you are allowed to publish whatever
you'd like on but you're gonna use the
social network that's created by
somebody else then you aren't beholden
to their rules sure we see the issue
here right you're the one who has a
problem with their rules really glad to
have our next guest I think he thinks
that I'm the boogeyman that's usually
people think when they come on this show
if they don't necessarily come from the
same political persuasion you can follow
him on Twitter at Josh Conn steam he's a
writer for TechCrunch misra constant
thank you for being here sir thank you I
mean I'm glad to have you now are you
are you here out of your own free will
or do we need to notify the authorities
there's someone putting the lotion on
its skin there that background oh yeah
I'm here on my own volition I'm hoping
to have a good civil discussion about
some really important topics okay so
you're not you are in fact this is your
own basement no this is the TechCrunch
office oh okay nice eh just boosting
morale in what happened Bob listen Josh
I wanted to talk with you because I saw
your article up here at TechCrunch and
it was titled silenced by free speech
and which you were putting forth I don't
want to misrepresent your putting forth
I get some solutions assertions
regarding the policing the treatment of
speech on social media platforms not
gonna lie I come at this from the other
point of view so I'd love to hear what
it is I guess in your own words you were
asserting with the article yeah so
modern social networks there's just a
fundamental in Korean currency with
being completely and unabashedly open to
all forms of replies and insults and
harassment and being a place for civil
discussion of important issues well well
you know free speech is critically
important that right was not designed
with the with in mind with people being
able to come to you shout in your face
and say these are their beliefs everyone
is welcome to speak their own beliefs
but I don't think other people are
necessarily obligated to listen or
that speech come into their house you
know whether you call that you somebody
coming into your front door and
screaming at you or coming to your
Twitter profile and screaming at you and
so I believe the social networks need to
do more to protect people from this kind
of harassment that's not protecting
people from having their own points of
view nobody should be censored for
having those perspectives if they're you
know tweeting them on their own profiles
but when it comes to replies where a lot
of this abuse happens I think that there
needs to be some changes made and
Twitter has announced a bunch of changes
to promote safety on its platform but
none of them right now address the
fundamental problem which is in replies
and so in silence by free speech I
discuss how well some social networks
have put up a defense that they're being
completely Pro free speech but in doing
so they're allowing harasser to actually
silence other people by bullying them
into being quiet and so Kay yes yeah but
you kind of unpacked a few things there
do you mind if I ask a couple of
questions sure so you started off with
the First Amendment so I'm interested so
why you started off there and mentioned
the founding fathers mentioned how it
wasn't they couldn't have conceived sort
of this inner connectivity as you put it
in your article first off before we get
off on that do you believe this is a
First Amendment issue or a Facebook
Twitter and YouTube have the right to do
what they want as a business issue
because you start off asserting First
Amendment wasn't designed with this
technology in mind yeah this is about
what Facebook and Twitter are doing on
their platforms as businesses they are
not a hold into to unequivocally allow
any type of speech even so that is where
what I'm discussing here but then why
start with First Amendment and then go
into businesses have the right to do it
with what they want to do that they're
completely separate they're unrelated
you invoke the first they're not
unrelated unfortunately because these
companies are saying that the First
Amendment and the free end free speech
are why they're allowing this abuse so
this is their their rationale for for
not policing their platforms or for
protecting victims is that it's all part
of free speech they're the ones pointing
to the First Amendment they're the ones
appointed in the first minute and that's
why the first paragraph and of your
article and the first thing you
mentioned is the First Amendment did not
account for this technology so that's
your argument in response to their
rationale I just want to make sure I'm
understanding this clearly yes okay
let's do that first where does that line
get drawn is it at the printing press is
it with a typewriter and it was a
computer is it with social media where
does the First Amendment still apply the
First Amendment plies to be those own
speech okay so that can be in similar
forms but so what were there was
technology though because that's that's
your assertion is that it didn't take
into account this interconnectivity the
technology that we currently have so I'm
just trying to clarify what your
position is because I'm not entirely
clear in the article and and you went
down a few different paths that I would
like to explore then how does technology
it could not be less relevant well it's
obviously very relevant because speech
is conducted through technology now it
is so I don't understand how you could
think those things are totally separate
they're separate on what you just said
that someone has the right to say
whatever they want but then you say that
the First Amendment didn't account for
current technology so I just asked you
where does it stop and you just said
it's in relation to your own speech so
to the First Amendment for example apply
when you're using the telephone speaking
freely with your family members does it
apply to your town crisis okay if you're
talking yeah if you're talking to
someone who consensually wants to speak
with you on the phone they're allowed to
say whatever you want but if you call
someone at all hours of the night over
and over again to scream at them you can
be charged for harassment sure can be
charged for stalking absolutely and is
it isn't it wonderful that with new
media social media like Facebook Twitter
you can block you can mute I think
that's the fundamental assertion that I
disagree with your presupposition that
people have to listen therefore the
people at the top from the top down at
Facebook Twitter YouTube need to do
something about it no one's forced to
use these applications and no one has to
listen you can't before caller ID and
you aren't a rotary phone someone called
you asked if your refrigerator was
running yet to say dammit and hang up
and hope it didn't happen again
now you know you can block it yeah but
what if somebody kept calling you from
different phone numbers every day a
different phone number you couldn't
block those right but that's already a
violation of the rules exactly but you
couldn't block those phone numbers
you're saying the blocking is fine but
if I called you from a different phone
number every day couldn't block buzzer
great I assume that you're obviously
drawing a connection here to stock
accounts to bought accounts of creating
multiple accounts for harassment
campaigns could I know you've written
about that and I would agree with you
but that's already a violation of the
rules you're suggesting new rules and
stricter enforcement so I guess my
question here is you say that free
speech isn't free if someone is
intimidated by somebody else's speech is
it am i misrepresenting what you've said
there or is that the general premise
yeah you're misrepresenting me here
someone has offended you people are you
know welcome to save views that offend
other people but when you start to
directly reply to people when you're
shoving that that perspective in
somebody else's face it becomes
different it's not about oh you're in
the street saying your point of view
that's so I can just walk away but if
every day you create a new Twitter
account and reply to me and put those
those messages into my timeline into my
own it's different
well it isn't allowed to do it on one
account but that hasn't stopped anyone
from creating new accounts to do that
harassment everyday so that's why I'm
saying that the current block options
are inaccurate okay well again that's
not really that's not really what you're
writing about in your article you're
talking about nothing somatic weapons
already heavily regulated right someone
can buy a semi-automatic weapon and
transform it that's illegal
it doesn't change the fact that it's
illegal it's already illegal to create
targeted harassment campaigns online
it's already illegal to stalk somebody
online people get banned for these
offences and the important thing is for
example threatening somebody you know
grievous bodily harm or calling people
to violent action or continually
targeting harassing the reason that
these policies are in place and aren't
allowed is because they mirror directly
our laws it's illegal to do that going a
step further beyond that which you
suggest in your article then that
becomes as you discuss it censoring
these were your words not mine
then you kind of become the
thought police yeah I'm not asking
anyone to be the thought police I'm just
saying that if you if you force people
to register their accounts to a phone
number then when if somebody is banned
like you said then that ban actually
sticks what you're saying is that the
ban works fine right now and it doesn't
you know that you know that anyone can
create a second account anonymously and
they can harass somebody again even if
they were banned yesterday and so yes
I'm saying that people should have to
register their accounts to a phone
number which makes it much more
difficult to create new accounts to
continue that harassment after they've
been banned for breaking the rules right
so okay so now we're moving for with
with solutions and I appreciate you
actually put forth a solution do you
think that a policy should be an account
directly tied to a phone number that's
at least one way to improve prove the
condition by increasing friction to
creating new harassment accounts okay
other ways to do that other signals
would be requiring that people have been
on the service for a long enough period
of time or that they don't have any
other signals that they haven't been
reported for other violations sure
do you support an tyfa being on twitter
or facebook that has nothing to do with
this topic right now it has everything
to do with it what about black lives
matter what about fight for fact I do I
do support black lives matter okay but
yeah but considering that maybe
something about this specific group but
I'm not aligned so disingenuous your
opinion to theirs because I know for a
fact that you've supported these groups
being on these social media platforms so
do I by the way but again unpopular
speech I have a problem with anonymity
by the way it breeds cowardice we can
both agree on that but unpopular speech
is speech that often needs to be
protected most so let's take int if a
black lives matter fight for 15 for
example they very often most often
aren't tied to an individual person and
phone number account should we shut down
all local chapters of anti phone Twitter
because it's anonymous there's no person
attached to it it's not about anonymity
it's about harassment you just said the
solution was a phone number so if
someone wants to remain anonymous if
somebody wants to send themselves I'm
using an example a very clear example of
which we would have some kind of
precedent here or
that don't set a phone number that don't
attach a private address or name to it
should they be removed well if they if
they create a new account and they've
been suspended for for breaking the
rules then yeah if they want to be able
to continue to reply to people but the
problem is rarely that these groups are
caught in the trouble is when people are
replying specifically to specific actors
and that's where the abuse comes from so
just because an account is anonymous or
is tweeting their own perspectives on
either side of the app on either side of
an issue that's not a problem the
problem is abuse directed at specific
people sure and that's why I that's what
the rules that I propose would help to
come back so we've just abandoned the
idea that you would need a phone number
to be attached to a Twitter account to
be created that that wouldn't apply to
groups no but if you want to create a
new a new Twitter account if you want to
be able to if you don't if you didn't
already register with a phone number
press if you want to be able to continue
to reply to people after being reported
then yeah you would need to register an
account is the standard reporting
because you've written extensively about
mass flagging and mass reporting
campaigns occurring from the alt-right
you've written about this people have
talked about this
so the standard that you just use not me
is being reported and you need a phone
number now you've said well no you
wouldn't need a phone number it's if
you're replying and if you've been
reported so let's say a group like an
tyfa has no phone number attached or
black lives matter or fight for 15 or
whatever it is the SEIU no phone number
attached this is an organization they've
replied they've been reported as
harassing remove them it would depend on
whether they were actually found to have
been harassing this has been reported
this is where we're going who determines
this what's your solution how do we fix
that who determines what is and is not
an infringement of someone else's speech
based on level of offense these services
need to put forward clear Terms of
Service that dictate what is of an
offense that is banned a ball or causes
a suspension thank you very hard to
realize that they already do are
controlling these services need to put
rules in place yes and the rules
currently are inadequate
they certainly are
not preventing abuse as we're seeing
about these produce problems all the
time so obviously they need to improve
their roles so you just said people so
you would you would advocate for human
input yeah you're gonna you're gonna
have to have humans to write these rules
there's no robot that's gonna write this
for you I don't understand the question
okay well let me clarify the question
assume I'm a dummy its algorithmic or
there's human input so Facebook YouTube
Twitter for example have argued that
it's not the byproduct of human input
they vehemently argued that it's
algorithmic now of course people on the
road isn't a so of course people on the
right let me let me finish what I'm what
I'm saying here I appreciate it let you
answer they said it's not human input as
someone personally who was I think your
site actually wrote about this
TechCrunch I certainly know was written
about engaged in Gizmodo when Facebook
was found to have had human input
determining pages that had to be
throttled and could not be viewed there
was Ted Cruz for president Chris Kyle
Foundation and yours truly and we had to
settle this legally so I've been through
this I've experienced it I've
experienced the wrath of human input
once said human doesn't like what you
have to say do you see how dangerous it
would be to simply give over the rights
in this capacity just to someone who can
change by the way it should change on
any given month
what if someone doesn't like what you
have to say next month instead of me
you're confusing completely different
issues you're talking about trending
topics on Facebook which had human
curators that looked at what was
surfaced by the algorithms know and then
you know somehow comparing that to the
rules about harassment there's totally
two different things no they're not
they're not because you talked about you
talked about people replying so we've
gone away from phone numbers we've gone
away from you said you said that humans
would have to determine if it was a
violation or not
did you know humans we posture right did
you okay yeah not you did you not say
that a human would have to determine if
it was a violation of the guidelines or
not Josh yes or no I said that humans
have to write them yes you want human
input so can you see problems with
because you keep trying to move away
from it you made that point I'm not
making it up people can go back to the
tail of the tape so
you were advocating for human input
could you not see how that might be
problematic based on the fact that
humans have inherent biases
yeah humans do have inherent biases but
if you want to write rules for social
networks no robot is gonna write those
rules for you I never said they sure
don't understand how do you how do you
propose on the other side we would
create rules for dictating how
harassment was treated but the rules
were written by algorithms that's like a
science fair never seen the rules damn
no I never no I never said the rules
should be written by algorithms and I
know the tech is kind of your one card
to play so you want to go back to that I
want to go back to what it is that you
said a human should determine what is a
violation of these guidelines you said a
human would have to go in because I said
what if people have rules that are
applied evenly and consistently across
the city who are advocating more human
input correct I'm advocating for human
input to write rules that are then
enforced both by algorithms and by human
moderators yes exactly so you're
advocating for more human input there we
go we've answered that question both on
rules which wasn't my point but
determining what is and what is not
abuse so alt right doesn't like what you
have to say they report you human
happens to be sympathetic to outright
your removed my position here is they
already have rules in place that mirror
the law there's one person for that
there's one person here who's advocating
for more than regulations that would
mirror the law that's yourself and I
haven't really heard a justification for
it again you're willing to give these
freedoms up online to a human to
determine what is and what is not
offensive and it's based on the premise
that you've written about that freedom
of speech is not free if your free
speech or my free speech silences or
intimidate someone else from speaking
freely this is the premise of your
article and I've heard it taught at
colleges across the country what
determines or who determines since
you've decided it should be a who
determines what is and is not okay to
say we're not talking about harassment
it's already not allowed we're not
talking about daxing it's already not
allowed we're talking about offensive
speech online which would be considered
a
violation of someone else's free speech
who decides and what is this violation
the owners of the services that you're
using for free yes you don't want to use
those services there is an open and
unmediated internet that you are allowed
to publish whatever you'd like on but
you're gonna use the social network
that's created by somebody else
then you aren't beholden to their rules
sure we see the issue here right you're
the one who has a problem with their
rules right the rules currently don't
protect people from harassment
sufficiently right so what new rules and
how do we enforce them what new rules
and who enforces them let's Zone in on
this what should be considered right now
what should be considered offensive
enough speech in your opinion to be
removed from the platform on consensual
nudity threats of violence on consensual
nudity groups that live I'm legal on a
platform sending dick pics or sending
pornography is allowed because last I
checked that's a violation of the
current services on Twitter and thing is
that yep but the rules are not being
properly enforced nor are they strong
enough and so this week Twitter
announced that it was creating stronger
rules to more expressly forbid on
consensual nudity threats of violence
and use by spit and hate groups that
have used violence in the past to get
their way sure yeah it's pretty clear so
yeah right exactly but your article
isn't about the rules the current rules
you're proposing new rules you're
talking about speech not just sending
nudity so I wear abuse happens and I'm
saying that if somebody is is recorded
and found to have been abusive then they
should not be allowed to reply to other
accounts with that abuse sure so outside
of nudity or current violations of their
service you wouldn't consider it to be
abuse sent for example if I respond
something that somebody doesn't like
they made him offensive we would both
agree that's not something that should
be a violation of abuse that depends on
context it depends on what you're saying
and how you phrase it okay current rules
what edition
lose you write civility is a tightrope
between chaos and censorship you talk
about needing new rules and enforcing
them
what new rules and how would they be
enforced by whom you just said you can
use that abused people can't what if
what if you feel like stalking slower
makes your point Josh what is abuse Josh
who determines abuse give okay let's do
this give me an exist just went through
it it's already illegal you propose new
rules in your article you propose
offensive speech be limited not nudity
not threatening with violence so what
would be abuse what right now that is
allowed would you disallow because
that's what you're advocating for I'm
just trying to get a straight answer
give me an example when somebody replies
to your account and tells you that they
want to hurt you but they want to hurt
your family and they said they say you
know awful unspeakable words to you and
they reply to you every day and then you
report them and they get banned and then
they created a new account and they do
that same thing the next day so that
every time you open Twitter you see that
content no matter how many accounts you
ban that's the kind of rule that I'm
trying to have that I'm advocating for
it already exists it doesn't because
this happens all the time to people and
if I'm Josh does that mean murder is
legal this isn't legal people need to
read you read your own article you were
a birder then you can't create a new
life the next day and then go murder
someone again that could be let's
operate differently than the real world
and I think that's a probably I do
understand what the First Amendment is
apparently because you go to the
founding in the First Amendment how it
couldn't possibly take into account
today's interconnectivity you're the one
who invokes the First Amendment I fully
understand how people operate on Twitter
and Facebook my grandmother does when
she sends four words of prairie dogs
testicles okay this is not a tech issue
just because you write for TechCrunch
we're talking about a freedom of speech
issue these rules already exist if you
commit murder you get punished if you
send nudity on Twitter if you commit
harassment you get banned to the best of
their abilities some get through just
like OJ got through your
indicating new rules saying that the
rules are not enough and that people
need to be in your own words you discuss
the the class hierarchy so let's get to
that systems of oppression you talk
about white men versus black children
let's go to that example that you read
about in your articles that we don't get
wishy-washy give that example to our
audience why it's a problem and what you
think Facebook or Twitter should do
about it
those are Facebook's rules and if you
want to quote my article you're welcome
to ok so you talked about how for
example in your article white men would
be protected under Facebook or if you
write something negative about white men
that could be removed correct that is
Facebook's perspective right will you
write about that and then you complain
that black children simultaneously would
not be protected
correct correct okay well facebook says
that if you have a protected class that
is protected against discrimination
which includes things like race
ethnicity religion what that term is
combined with an unprotected class like
age then suddenly the whole statement is
not protected under its abuse rules and
so yeah I think that just because
somebody says that someone is a white
old man that they shouldn't be subject
to abuse when white man is not allowed
to be abused and that seems pretty
cleared pretty simple to me right like
if somebody was like all white grandmas
are terrible but they so what you think
that that should be that that's abuse or
they compared if when especially when
all white people are you know are awful
but that is abuse the the Deline
differentiating those makes no sense and
Facebook has implemented that that rule
system but it just needs to be improved
okay now the reason I bring this stuff
is because when I bring up examples from
your article you move to a different
example this is a concrete example we
can use and I think it's disingenuous
you can tell me if you think I'm wrong
so you say white men would be protected
black children would not I'm not saying
that this way it looks rule quit yeah I
know I know I know any
problem with the rule isn't and its
current implementation as you just
expressed very articulately so white men
is protected black children are not let
me ask you this is black men protected
yeah black man is protect what about
white children not protected so you kind
of injected race into an issue where it
was irrelevant to the current rules on
Facebook that's the issue isn't there a
quite again if your your issue is I'll
be reductive we can do that if you take
into account ageism fine but use an
example of a white man and black
children and that's a disingenuous
example as the face to people those two
groups deserve equal protection I don't
think that ageism is the same as race I
don't think that age is as relevant and
clearly Facebook doesn't I disingenuous
examples are protected when children
aren't sure so you're agreeing that
people being abused based on their race
is an OK by we didn't discuss anyone
being abused here we're not discussing
direct abuse we are discussing you
mentioned classes who would be protected
on Facebook and who wouldn't he said
white man would black children wouldn't
the fact is white shoulder issue but you
write consistently about racial issues
and minorities who need to be protected
and I understand where you're coming
from as a more of a leftist you just
said black lives matter definitely on
Twitter even if they don't have phone
numbers so my question becomes you've
also mentioned actors I think you you've
talked about Leslie Jones before can we
acknowledge that maybe systems of power
are different than just race gender
maybe Leslie Jones has more power to
harass with her millions of followers
than a straight white sis male who only
has a handful no abuse is about the way
that people who use the platform not how
many people follow it the potential for
abuse because you systems if somebody
has hate in their heart so yeah it
doesn't matter how many followers you
have if you say hateful things you're
abusive
you've talked systemically about social
media and
needing to assist with and protect
marginalized classes correct yes
okay so my point is this abuses of power
can be significantly more harmful with
someone who may be a black female like
let's say Leslie Jones and she creates a
target harassment campaign or take your
pick as opposed to a straight sis white
male should that not be taken into
account equally when enforcing these
rules no the content of the abuse should
be the content is this well no because
you're right in your article about
marginalized classes and systems of
oppression and how you have not done
enough to correct this how white males
need to do more to correct this correct
incorrect so do you think that you have
less power despite your ethnicity and
your gender and Wesley Jones because
absolutely because she has more Twitter
followers I don't use I don't need to I
can just go on Twitter we're talking
about abuses of Twitter rules here Josh
remember this is your article or not be
able to abuse these guidelines more
effectively and more powerfully than say
my producer myself my point is you use a
disingenuous example as we've just
discussed and you look at everything
through the prism of race or gender
you're not taking everything into a
Catholic and you want people who share
your opinion through the lens of race
and gender I'm saying that abuses abuse
okay abuse is abuse
so we've just acknowledged in the
platform of Twitter that someone who
would have significantly more power on
Twitter would be capable of
significantly greater abuses no we're
saying that the content of the abuse is
what matters it doesn't matter does the
content is the same I'm PO I'm doing the
same kind of thing a targeted harassment
campaign Leslie Jones is let's say I
wrote is and you know that I didn't say
she did Josh so why don't you pick an
alt right figure whose
coordinated one of these abuse figure
these abuse campaigns who has lots of
flowers and you can use them as your
example okay you pick one no I'm saying
you're the one who's picking random
example I was using them as an example
because you've written about Leslie
Jones so use leave so if you want you
pick another another figure does abuse I
don't know I'm not alright so you can
pick one and we could compare it and use
a hypothetical scenario take any one you
want so you don't know and but you're
just randomly picking random people but
you said you don't know I didn't
randomly pick someone and say that she
committed any kind of abuse on Twitter I
was talking about systems of power as
you write about in your article saying
that as a white male you haven't done
enough to correct this you effectively
call to action other white males to
correct this injustice online correct or
incorrect am i misrepresenting you there
yeah I think with power should speak up
for victims and those who are abused and
you believe that someone has more power
simply because he is white and straight
online than someone who has 800 times
the followers and reach and financial
backing now what I'm saying is that the
content of someone's abuse is what needs
to be considered not how many followers
they have yes the content should be
considered so content being equal let's
say all right person okay does the exact
same thing that I don't know Leslie
Jones let's say Will Smith I don't know
if he's on Twitter I'm trying to take
any minority or I'm not a specific
minority maybe he's not on Twitter I
have no idea John about minority maybe
you just pick two white people one with
more followers your example where you
call on people to fix these systems of
oppression you specifically call on
Facebook Twitter and white male writers
to rectify the situation that's what you
write about based on race your entire
article is written through the prism of
race and what I'm saying is what you
want yes you read up race into
everything apparently but yeah I agree
white not remix and up for those who are
reviews okay you know you don't see that
as a statement based entirely on race do
you agree that the white men who are
some of the most powerful people in the
world the people who are naturally
advantaged by the current ingest systems
you
think that that what I just don't
understand you don't think that they
should stand up for our victims no I
think everybody should right but should
white men stand up for victims they
would be included amongst everybody yeah
but do you think that they might have
outsized in responsibility because they
have outsized power no I just based it
on the content right exactly so so we
both agreed then then what matters just
base it on the content you just brought
up soon why would what white men could
not be less relevant that's my point we
agree whether it's a white man or a
black female the abuse is the abuse and
the abuse of power can be more powerful
if this person has a much greater
platform and my point is your call to
action as you just did now I'm glad that
we've clarified is two white men to
correct these institutional forms of
discrimination and that is the
presupposition of your new rules and
guidelines when dictating what speech is
and is not allowed and it doesn't do men
do you need to stand up for victims of
abuse right how about good men yeah all
good news why not good men do you not
consider it for the ones who are
unnaturally privileged in this system
and so they need to be oh they need to
be the ones willing to stand up whether
it's sexual assault and harassment
whether it's online abuse white men who
control a lot of things in this world do
need to stand up and stand with victims
but it seems pretty reasonable you know
it's the same way that you know major
politicians who hold power in countries
around the world need to stand up for
victims of abuse and for Human Rights
okay so would you believe when Barack
Obama was president that this man was
more powerful than say the white man
tilling the cornfields I'm not sure
about your what I would say is that the
president is more powerful than an
average citizen yes a black president
again because you said white men need to
fix this problem I said how about good
men right a black president Barack Obama
would he or and you just use politicians
as an example I'm following your logic
or service but you sure did
whereas what most white men have not are
a lot of white men have not against
problems they're the danger this is what
you've written about in your article
correct yeah yes and you don't see that
as being written through the prism of
race no I agree I think that saying
white men specifically and only seeing
systems of power through the prism of
race is seeing it through the prism of
race you don't so perfect world here
what you're joining is a race race as if
it's not a problem in this country and
that's just ridiculously false no I
didn't do so you really think that
everyone is already treated equally and
so everyone should stand up equally for
abuse then you clearly have a misguided
view of the world you don't think that
everyone should equally stand up in the
face of abuse or do but I sure don't
think that everyone is equally
privileged to stand up and that's why
those with more power
I don't believe everyone is equally
privileged on that we agree I simply
don't see privilege exclusively through
the lenses of race and gender my point
is there are people who can be abused on
these social media platforms simply for
having unpopular views regardless of
whether a white black gay straight trans
male female that's my point that happens
every day and you see that all the time
unpopular viewpoints it's a pendulum
that swings for example you know right
now yours would be less popular amongst
many people in the tech community or
people with social media who would
advocate for more open platforms I think
your views shouldn't be censored to use
your words I think you should be as free
to express it as I am and I would like
to see rules from fishing Twitter and I
would absolutely even if you even if you
at replied me a thousand times a day
which would likely be a violation of
their guidelines I would defend your
right to do it you're the one advocating
the opposite and you're advocating the
opposite through your article again
exclusively through the prism of race
and gender you're right I'm advocating
against abuse you nailed it yes yes
you're advocating against abuse and
attributing abuse exclusively to people
of a given race or gender no in a system
of classes
closing thoughts what happens in
Facebook Twitter YouTube and your
perfect world what app
right now what is YouTube for example
missing my article was about Facebook
and Twitter okay what is Facebook and
twelve okay two problems Facebook needs
to create policies that understand where
privilege lies and does not protect
people or does not allow use of certain
races just because there's a modifier
like age attached to them and Twitter
needs to create better rules to prevent
abuse through the reply system sure
you're right for a major publication
like TechCrunch and we're an independent
outlets so I would love to see you go on
your own and see where the privilege
lies that's my point we just need to let
free speech be free speech for all
regardless of race gender orientation
then it becomes a really simple simple
issue may sound reductive hey maybe it
is either it sounds like it means that
people who are abused don't need any
special help yeah I know Josh thank you
so much we'll have you back and we'll
talk about this more I'm sure you'll
write about it no doubt people you can
comment and see where your opinions line
up I appreciate Josh coming on here it's
very difficult often for us to get
people with opposing viewpoints to
discuss these issues I really do
appreciate it Josh thank you very much
sir and we'll have you back hey did you
like this video it what you didn't oh
you're a cat person well that makes
sense disregard him and or her /z
everyone else hit the subscribe button
and leave your comment below as to why
you like this video i you know what
crazy cat you can get back you can you
can comment below to as to why you don't
like it